we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p our friend billy
harrison called in he really thinks
keystone xl would lower gas prices
listen to this
david pac-man yeah
billy harrison again
you're saying
president biden or any president for
that matter
has nothing to do
with the price of gas almost nothing to
do i've explained the three things
presidents can do
so
i've called you several times to debate
seems like you never played my
clip
i actually have played a number of
billy's clips a voicemail on your show
i wouldn't either if i was you because i
make you look stupid right
but your spending president has nothing
to do with gas prices yet
joe biden first day in office accounts
for keystone pipeline
that's one way it affects gas prices
yeah no unfortunately that's not true
remember uh keystone pipeline phases one
through three are up and running what
joe biden did was stop construction of
the fourth phase of keystone xl
keystone is not an oil field it's only a
pipeline it's a way to transport the oil
the oil is still coming in it's just
coming in through other means and the
best estimates we have are that phase
four of keystone xl when completed and
it wouldn't even be done now
if biden had started
continued construction it wouldn't even
be done now but when completed
phase four of keystone xl would only
have increased oil production by one
percent would have no impact on the
price of gas sorry billy we've got a
great bonus show for you today sign up
at
joinpackman.com to get instant access i
will see you then